[Musique]
vingt ans après les 7 mars font peau
neuve
précurseur ce centre intégré ancien fer
de lance de la vie nouvelle franchi une
autre étape de sa maturité
alors que l'engouement s'est déplacé
vers l'est les sept marc affiche de
nouvelles ambitions urbaine face à un
isolement dont ils font aujourd'hui les
frais ce centre a perdu son attractivité
les gens ne viennent plus il est devenu
triste il faut donc leur structure et
que nous avons nous avons cherché à
adapter
nous avons vu que c'était tout à fait
insuffisant c'est une véritable
transformation laquelle il faut procéder
en termes d'architecturé cette volonté
de changement entraîne de sérieux
bouleversements les plus importants sont
le déplacement de l'intermarché vers le
rond-point de cette marque qui lui
évitera de l'actuelle station service
située près du commissariat ainsi que de
nouvelles places de parking
autre modification de taille
l'élargissement des boyaux ou des rues
étroites propice aux courants d'air
ainsi que la destruction de passerelles
et l'aménagement des accès souterrain
toutes ces mesures s'accompagnent en de
la construction de nouveaux logements
offriront de nouvelles perspectives tant
sur le plan de leur architecture que de
la vie on sait maintenant que vu la
présence des hauts champs des
centre-ville de saint-quentin et autres
ce type de sens commercial marche mal
donc il faut qu'ils marchent au louvre
on perd mais du stationnement en
périphérie on remontre tous les
commerces ont fait des passages abriter
citera pour que les rues deviennent
accueillant vivant et dynamique destinée
à redynamiser le centre à la demande des
commerçants qui traverse actuellement
une passe difficile
la restructuration 17 mar n'en reste pas
moins un pari social celui d'améliorer
le cadre de vie les élans courtois pour
l'avenir dans l'immédiat
et avant que cette transformation ne
prenne corps il faudra qu aux termes de
l' enquête publique qui débute le 22
avril prochain la nouvelle zac proposée
par le pays soit acceptée par les
pouvoirs publics
[Musique]
une fumée blanche et épaisse envahi
l'atrium de 28 mètres du centre
commercial sqy ouest
un exercice de simulation incendie pour
tester les ouvrages de désenfumage deux
extracteurs qui se déclenche
automatiquement dès lors qu'une fumée
est détecté par un boîtier électronique
30 secondes après la mise en fait d'un
mélange constitué de fécule de nitrate
de potassium et de lactose les
extracteurs se met en route laissée
globalement est positive quelques
réglages notamment sont quand même à à
part faire pour équilibrer les
différences de pression entre le gros
volumes qu'on axa mille mètres cubes et
les volumes adjacents du centre
ce sont des réglages techniques qui
peuvent être faits et piloté directement
par les techniciens qui sont
actuellement sur le centre car tout doit
être finalisé pour le 4 novembre
prochain date du passage de la
commission technique qui autorisera ou
non l'ouverture du centre et surtout
celle du complexe cinématographique au
troisième étage de skywest les ouvriers
terminent en effet le gros oeuvre
l'opération du jour la pause écran dans
les deux salles de 477 place c'est un
écran géant donc il a 19 mètres de base
sont des écrans comme peut y avoir
derrière moi donc des écrans qui sont
cintrées donc arrondis pour avoir une
bonne visibilité de n'importe quel siège
de notre salle sont des écrans qui sont
à créquy son micro perforé pour pouvoir
permettre au 905 l'ia derrière de
restituer le son dans les meilleures
conditions
des lamelles de goise sont aussi
installés au mur pour offrir un jeu de
lumière aux spectateurs avec ses seize
salles et c'est 3612 fauteuil
ce complexe cinématographique sera le
troisième plus grand du gc de france
[Musique]